she just won I could have spent more
time Brady Bunch stars mourn the loss of
their TV mom Florence Henderson she's
the kind of mom that you want even if
you had a mom like that you take another
one and if you didn't have a mom like
that she represented that mom that you
didn't have and it's a terrible tragedy
that we've all we won't lost her but we
all own her you know I know that I will
live being Who I am with her because you
know she's had a very important role in
my life and I'm you know a good deal of
Who I am because of her I was just
waking up when when I got the news so it
it was it stunned me and it still has it
was the her forces passing he was very
unexpected it was just a wonderful kind
of warm and stern mothering figure and
she to me with somebody I just never
wanted to disappoint I just had such
high esteem for and I think for
everybody I think that's what we all
react to is that she's just she's the
kind of mom that you want Barry Williams
aka Greg Brady got choked up when he
shared the last words he would want to
say to his on-screen mom I love you I
think it's important to know that many
people share this loss that she will be
remembered she'll be loved for a long
time